and for the first time ever this year's
Kennedy Center Honors celebrates a TV
show Sesame Street has revolutionized
how we think about childhood and the
world the ceremony which airs this
Sunday on CBS paid tribute to the
program's co-creators Lloyd Morissette
and Joan Ganz Cooney and especially the
Muppets hey big bird can I tell you how
to get to Sesame Street oh you've been
for fifty years it's been the favorite
address for kids to learn the alphabet
see if ok that's good enough for me
learn to count or learn about life maybe
when you're happy tell me why is Sesame
Street such a special place it's a place
where no matter who you are what you
look like you're welcome all of those
people they are our friends not only are
the Muppets all different colors on
Sesame Street from the beginning so were
the actors and I was stunned these
people of color in a neighborhood that
look like my neighborhood Sonia Manzano
was 21 when she joined the cast in the
third season in 1971 one of the first
Latino actors to have a lead role on TV
she would play Maria for 44 years there
aren't that many actors who play a part
as long as you did I got it right why
did you stick with it so long because
the needs of the kids changed every year
I grew up on Sesame Street we were
allowed to age which was unheard of the
show had a mission right from the
beginning the show came out of the civil
rights movement we were gonna change the
world I understood what the mission of
the show was very pretty the goal was to
have children entering school prepared
to succeed an idea hatched when Lloyd
Morissette then with the Carnegie
Corporation had dinner with Joan Ganz
Cooney a producer with Public Television
and after dinner I asked her and Joan do
you think television could be used to
teach young children that's the
beginning ganz cooney studied the idea
wrote this report and realized as she
told 60 minutes in 2017 it would be
demonstrating what children's television
could do for children and that that
would be huge but the Muppets almost
weren't part of the show Jim Henson did
not want to do a children's show because
he didn't want to be identified as a
children's entertainer but Henson came
around a time taken away and in 1969
Sesame Street went on the air Sally you
never seen the street like Sesame Street
what was the show like in the early days
it was very raw it was almost like live
television we would do one rehearsal and
then you take it had you ever acted with
puppets before no no I kept looking down
at the puppeteer at my feet until Frank
Oz who plays Grover said quit looking at
that man down there
I was shaken Franca's Jim Henson and
Caroll Spinney who played Big Bird and
Oscar the Grouch have since been
succeeded by a second generation of
puppeteers we're actors from the elbow
up Matt Vogel who now performs Big Bird
and the count is puppet captain for the
show we'll go out and do live shows and
we will go in with the puppet on our arm
and a child in front of us a child does
not see us at all they see those
characters and they believe in them
instantly it does not matter at all that
we are there this is everyone it seems
has a favorite Muppet you comfortable
Grover yes Oh Betty yes Grover has
always been mine what kinds of things
are you curious about Grover
I am bunny rabbits I am curious about
why the sky is blue and not polka dot I
am curious if the letter O is jealous F
they let their cue because it has that
little tail thing on it do you know the
answer
do not know the answer I'm also curious
right now if your mommy usually dresses
you
not anymore Grover no no is that why you
forgot to wear your tie sorry do you
feel disrespected I'm not wearing
anything not the problem so how do you
feel about winning the Kennedy Center
Honors like a prize you kept in a cereal
box is that the kind of prize you're
talking about well it's not a bowling
trophy
a prize for the cast and crew of a show
that half a century after its creation
is still enlightening children and their
parents
that's hard to do anything you're
looking at your feet menu but they're so
they're so compelling you end up you
ended up well they are engaging because
they're so quick witted and funny like
it's a letter Oh jealous of the letter Q
it's so silly but it's funny and they're
very physical actors and they don't get
credit for that I don't think it's like
holding your arm up for 30 minutes yeah
and as Matt does it's it's you know he
takes that costume off between every
scene because it's so heavy and you know
it was funny you seem to get such a kick
heaven I spent a lot of time for those
characters when my kids were growing up
so it was a thrill for me we all did to
be with them
you